Joshua Wong and Agnes Chow left police
headquarters on their way to court the
founders of the pro-democracy party
nemesis toe had been charged with
inciting and taking part in an allure
protest outside police headquarters in
June their court appearance was brief
both were released on bail we shall not
surrender and I urge international
communities could send a clear message
to President Xi sending troops or using
emergency ordinance is not the way out
we will continue our fights opposition
politician Chang Chun Thai a member of
the Hong Kong Legislative Council was
also detained and on Thursday the leader
of the band independence group Andy Chan
was arrested before boarding a flight to
Japan he's been accused of rioting and
assaulting a police officer in July
police have now confirmed seven arrests
over the past two days critics call it a
case of white terror by police
intimidation and an attempt to silence
protesters the demonstrations began more
than three months ago prompted by a
controversial extradition bill but they
quickly morphed into a wider discontent
and what has seen as China's growing
influence in Hong Kong affairs all these
are iconic young leaders arrests
together could send out some bitter
chilling effect around Hong Kong to
scare the people from taking to the
street tomorrow we arrest a person as
soon as we have gather sufficient
evidence to prove his or her offense the
allocation that we time our arrest is
totally false a mass prayer democracy
rally planned for Saturday has been
cancelled after organizers failed to get
the go-ahead in the Hong Kong Court of
Appeal on Wednesday night Chinese
military were filmed driving through
Hong Kong and what was described as a
routine rotation of soldiers from the
mainland on Friday state-owned media
warned if the situation in Hong Kong
worsens Chinese soldiers would have
quote no reason to sit on their hands
and it says the People's Liberation Army
Garrison in Hong Kong was not merely a
symbol of Chinese sovereignty over the
city despite the arrest and the
cancellation of Saturday's rally some
pro-democracy groups are urging
protesters to go ahead and demonstrate
over the weekend they've described the
police action as white terror and what
residents to maintain pressure on the
government to dump this bill the
government has suspended the proposed
extradition law but critics wanted
officially thrown out more than 900
people have been arrested since the
protests began in June and these latest
arrests are unlikely to discourage
people from continuing to express their
anger at the Hong Kong government Sarah
Clark al Jazeera Hong Kong